this talk is not going to be about any
magic solutions to your cicd problems if
you're interested in that i i don't know
what to tell you it's this stuff is hard
um
these are lessons we've learned at ivan
from trying to do this with you know
thousands and thousands of vms uh
systems that spin up vms up and down all
the time use a lot of resources
uh there's no easy way around this but
as you scale this stuff gets hard we're
also not talking about cool ways to test
your system
um i've heard talks about uh you know
things like jepson or other or fuzz
testing or fun you know testing tools
it's all great um you know there's
things that will unplug network
interfaces to try and verify your the
guarantees your system tries to make
about uh consistency um and uh we're not
doing that i would love to do that
someday but it's not this talk
uh this is more practical and grounded i
hope um this is not a pitch for a
particular tool uh if you use jenkins if
you use gitlab if you use circle ci i
don't care
i mean i have my opinions about those
systems but i'm not going to tell you
that one solution solves all your
problems
when i
started this talk uh when i was going to
submit it i actually wanted to call it
effective ci cd for large complex
systems but i kind of realized i hated
that because i hate complexity it's
actually the bane of my existence
testing a complex system is really hard
and really the goal
of this talk and what i hope you get out
of it is that we want to find simplicity
wherever we can in order to tackle these
problems it's a constant battle because
things get complex with scale then
things get complex with scope it makes
things hard
but
we will really don't win in the battle
against complexity because we have
combinatorial explosions we are fighting
against you know a
complexity that will try to consume us
and we can never hope to scale our own
resources up to meet that challenge
without finding some simplicity in the
middle of all of it
so what is a large system why am i
talking about large systems
oh well one's the the the thing that one
of the things that berlin is buzzing
about right now is scale and when we get
big things get complicated when you have
a lot of data it takes a long time to
move it around when you have to manage
lots of systems
things happen that wouldn't happen
before and there's mathematical reasons
why that's the case things just get
harder and
in general a lot of things just were not
designed with certain scales in mind
when they when they built them in the
first place and we take things to new
heights it gets harder
there's also the more classical you know
way maybe you heard of scope creep we
used to talk about this a lot more i
feel than we do now uh we talk about
scale a lot these days but scope is
still a thing uh as you add more
features to your system as you get that
extra demand oh i wanted it to do this
this and that as well as the thing i
originally told you you add more
conditions you add more complexity to
your system that makes it larger we also
grow things in terms of lines of code
as someone who deals with ci cd a lot as
someone who deals with with growing code
bases this is a problem it's more code
to test it's a greater liability
we haven't done a lot of studies on you
know
the quality of code in general but one
thing we do know pretty well is that
more code means more bugs so it gets
harder when you have bigger code bases
um
one thing that i think is really
instructive when thinking about quality
and thinking about how we get things
shipped
in software is to compare to other
industries
in the automobile industry
what do you may ask a question what do
you think that it takes for the typical
new model car to go from conception to
you know it's in a showroom floor it's
in a dealership
how long do you think
it's about five years is about about
actually five to six years is about the
correct reasoning for that so what if
you're a ceo or your project manager or
some major stakeholder for you came to
you and asked you uh hey i want to ship
this new software feature and you told
them it'll take about five to six years
you'd be lapped out of the room you'd be
lapped out of the industry they wouldn't
give you a job again so um because
that's not the expectation that we have
in software like things are just easier
for us we don't have to deal with the uh
you know the physical logistics of real
production uh and
that's awesome it lets us do things that
other industries could only dream of
but it comes with this problem of we can
kind of outrun ourselves in terms of
complexity pretty easily
how many vms can you spend up in 15
minutes
how many do you think
thousands um how i mean how much data
and so there's a lot of data people here
how much uh data can you store in 15
minutes
you just generate random data what do
you think
terabyte i don't know the action of the
answer at some point you'll be limited
by by either you know your network
bandwidth or uh your quotas or credit
card you know like at some point there's
a limit that's coming into play
no other industry gets this ability so
we have this crazy scaling ability that
nobody else does and it comes with great
with other problems because you can ship
a feature and you know you know that it
doesn't take you five to six years it
can you can ship a feature in two or
three days
sometimes you can also destroy a company
in 10 minutes so
we have to worry about quality we have
we have to have some checks in it and uh
how do we maintain equality and systems
that grow this big this fast uh do we
hire large qa departments
does anybody work in a company that has
a very large qa department for a product
anybody here i'm curious
so
one person in this this room uh it's not
how we do things anymore uh it just
because one thing it's really slow uh
it's not always a bad call
but it's just not how we do things in
software anymore we use ci cd
which asks some really simple questions
about the code we make on a regular
basis
ask can i build it
is it okay to merge these changes can i
merge them into can i integrate them
back into uh that's the integration
question and continuous integration can
i integrate them back into my pipeline
and can i deploy or deliver it to the
next level um
that's how we we approach these things
these days
these are fundamentally reductive
questions we take a lot of complexity
about what the state of our system and
reduce them to very very simple binaries
of yes or no and these questions are
reductive because the actions we take
are reductive uh it's it's you either
have built your software you have not it
the build you know worked or didn't
it uh you know you can merge it or you
cannot there's no half merge i mean you
can rewrite the code and do less of it
but that's still there's no half merge
uh there's no real half deploy there
kind of is but we'll get to that um but
you still have to ship it somewhere and
it's either shipped or it isn't
so real systems
unlike that binary tend to look more
like this this is just a you know i
scraped some grafana page from the
internet but you know when i ask is
is it up i don't get a simple answer i
get this i get a bunch of different data
and i get oh maybe something's kind of
in the red here and this looks okay and
this is just i think one cluster you
know uh
in a grafana page here but when we're
talking about large systems there's
typically always kind of a more complex
answer to the question of is it working
if you ever see a status page you know
status dot insert your favorite
system dot io here
you'll uh you know there'll be a bunch
of green dots those are lies
those are lies that someone has put
there to make you feel better because
there's always something going on behind
the scenes that that's probably bad it's
just being taken care of and they
haven't updated the page to say okay
this is in a great estate or there's an
outage
but ci cd is fundamentally pass fail
that's a much simpler picture than than
the real picture of a complex system
now is you might think that's a bad
thing we'll reduce we're taking away
information but not really remember the
actions we take based on this are
themselves reductive
so we need this simplicity you know we
need red and green builds otherwise we
end up with a bunch of brown and
dealing with this as an operator when
someone gives you in like incomplete
inconclusive information well it feels
like poop emoji
it's not
you have to if someone gives you a test
report and says figure out whether this
needs to be deployed or not
it's not fun
unfortunately in order to reduce this
this all down we need some kind of
reducing function and
typically that reducing function is and
does test one pass and does test two
pass and does test three pass and just
test four pass on and on and on do all
my tests pass
mathematically this starts to become a
problem because
any one of these the more tests we get
any one of these tests can make the
whole thing fail
we could do things like say like a
certain number of things fail but that
comes with its own set of problems but
typically this is actually what we want
but at a say a 1.1 failure rate
say one out of a thousand times you have
a test that can fail and any test can
fail a cert true can fail if your
computer you know turns off in the
middle of the operation um any test can
fail just they have different rates of
failure
of uncaused failure
uh but at that 1.1 failure rate it only
takes about
220 tests before you start to see a 20
failure of the overall system it only
takes 693 before you it starts becoming
more likely than not
that your test fails
so as you add more tests you start to
introduce this problem of flakiness
over and over and over so systems
actually get much harder than that in
that
case this can be exacerbated as well by
tests that rely on more moving parts
which makes them makes that that flake
rate you know change quite a bit it can
go up
one of the ways that people have dealt
with this traditionally and i mean this
still is an okay way to deal with it
sometimes is to retry things that fail
this assumes that you can have retriable
code which is not always an easy
assumption particularly when state is
involved
and it can break test isolation
depending on how you set up your your
your test
but more crucially it adds a lot of time
uh if you have to retry things over and
over again that can is especially in
cases when you have a legitimate failure
uh that you need to be informing your
developer about retrying an expensive
test can add minutes and even hours to
test sometimes it's not necessarily a
bad solution but it's not the only one
we should be looking at
especially when you consider the number
of tests we actually need to to verify
the behavior of software
this ugly picture
is an example of a system with say four
components
each one of these components has some
interaction with the other components
some number of interactions with the
other components so it could be a method
call it could be a uh it could be a
different branch that the code takes as
a result of a different parameter
it doesn't matter this is simplified for
the purpose of an illustration
but although ugly it's not that big of a
system it's four components with uh you
know three to six interactions each
but if i want to test that every
possible combination of that that grows
very quickly
just this small thing i need i need uh
1800 tests to exercise every possible
combination of it
what percentage of tests are we actually
going to write
if you need to write 1800 tests to test
the system how many are you going to
write
zero that's that's a good
i think somewhere most but i actually
used i should put zero percent somewhere
in you know in that range like uh
how many of those um
do we do we have do we know probably not
if we if we've glommed our systems
together like this we probably don't
even know how much we have or how much
we even need um you probably don't
actually need all of these tests maybe
some of these combinations are
unreachable or so irrelevant they don't
matter but do you know
no you just you just ship it whatever um
there's uh
you know some other ways we can deal
with this this growing number of tests
if you keep writing tests to try and
fight this battle against combinatorial
complexity uh but then you you can do
things like parallelizing tests which
you know we do uh
at ivan and a lot of places do because
you need to to get things faster but you
start running into even more problems as
a result of this you have resource
contention you ever had a test that that
failed because another test was eating
all its memory that's a problem we have
there are ways of dealing with it but
it's again that's complexity
um there are race conditions that can
happen not all code is meant to be
tested together and getting good
isolation between those things can be
hard
um
what if you're using external resources
uh i know one of the things that we do
at ivan is we have a we have a
distributed lock um
on systems that we test
in order to you know to maximize
resource utility usage for tests that
require
lots of vms
if you're having a distributed lock in
your tests
uh you're having tests that themselves
need test code which starts to get
really complicated distributed locks are
not simple pieces of software to write
and they're hard to get and they're easy
to get wrong
so when you have test cases that then
itself need test cases
you start realizing you're fighting
complexity with more complexity and
maybe there's a better answer
the best way i know to escape this is
actually to take a page from the auto
parts the auto industry and start using
parts use components
physical industries have to do this
because there's just no way to bring
their products to market without doing
this if you try to build a car the way
we build software then you'd run out of
money really fast because you'd be
making uh uh if you if you took a part
and you made for a car and as soon as
you finish making it you just screwed it
right back on the car and then you put
it all together and tried to test it
that wouldn't work and so um it doesn't
work in software either but we do it a
lot all the time
uh i mean we can kind of make it work
because we we're lucky and we're in
we tend to ignore this component thing
until it's a little too late um i want
to be clear that components can be
anything i'm not here to tell everyone
that you need to go start writing
microservices so you can test don't take
that message away that's not what i'm
saying
uh you can functions classes modules
whatever facility for isolating things
that your language or environment has
those are all things that can be
components um you can use ship libraries
internally within your company you can
do service oriented architectures for
this that that's another thing that can
be considered a component in fact you
can you can consider microservices
architectures as a way of
architecturally guaranteeing that there
are some component boundaries
but it's not necessary to do these kinds
of things
an important element of components at
least in what i mean is that they have
contracts in the same way that an auto
manufacturer would expect that their
suppliers build components to spec we
need all the constituent parts of our
software to have specifications that we
know what they can be tested to
i'm not going to i don't miss my
contract i don't necessarily mean
something very specific like design by
contract which has specific ideas about
pre and post conditions that's cool
that's an interesting topic you can
google that uh search that it's great
but i want to mean something more
generic just software component is what
does this thing need to work what are
its inputs what are its dependencies
what does it do or side effects and what
are its return values and what are its
failure modes how can it fail
that alone is a pretty powerful
tool for simplifying our software
because it means that i don't have to
write a test over a combinatorial
explosion of things because i don't have
to put everything together i can test
each part to contract
and
this this you might have to go on a leap
of faith with me this actually reduces a
combinatorial program problem to a
linear problem because now i need to
write a set number of tests per per
component that i write so uh versus
versus that that huge combinatorial
explosion that we saw before
um that doesn't mean i'm never going to
write tests that cover the whole thing
but but this really makes the whole
thing much more tractable and it gives
it puts us on track to uh
to have them uh the kind of rapid
feedback that we want in ci
it also
having components
gives us this property that i like to
call localizability i'm pretty sure i
made that word up but i hope you can
figure out what i mean by it it means
that
you can assign causes and find locations
when you encounter problems
uh how many
people here have a situation where some
of your best devs spend a lot of their
time looking for investigating code
looking for complex problems that result
from interactions between
weird parts of the code
yeah it happens all the time like you
and that's your best developers often
that are that are spending a lot of time
doing those kinds of things
having more clear contracts on what
things shouldn't do tends to make this
easier it doesn't perfectly solve it
you're still going to have weird
interactions that come up from time to
time but generally speaking you'll see
oh this component failed in its contract
that's either the failure of the
implementation or it's an under
specification in the contract
with this in mind we can start talking
about kind of what a good cicd system is
going to look like uh
ci cd is of course it's not jenkins a
lot of people what is ci cd or it's it's
jenkins that that's and or things that
are replaced jenkins like uh git github
uh actions or
get lab or whatever else you might use a
solution you might be using um
ci cd is a set of practices and uh
that's about you know continuously
integrating code based on rapid feedback
it should be get your system should be
helping you get confidence to merge uh
and confidence to know when to deploy if
it's not doing that and if someone doing
that let you then you do that in a fast
way then it's failing in its job
fundamentally it is a system of gates it
is again binary questions that happen at
different points what does it look like
normally when you when you you when you
have a commit
it's going to get automatically trigger
a continuous integration process that
will happen before you merge
you're going to run linting on your code
you're going to say does this look good
you're going to run your build
if you
some of you may use dynamic languages
which don't strictly need to compile but
often there's still build elements
involved like installing dependencies or
doing code generation or other things
that might need to happen in order for
your source to be ready to test
after that you want to have fail fast
tests i really hesitate to use words
like unit tests because people will now
spend hours arguing over what that means
i don't care what i care is that they
are fast and uh they they are low
resource usage
so whatever you want to call that is
fine with me those things you can run in
30 seconds to a minute that gives you
fast feedback to developers uh you know
is this basically right
then after that you can have some more
thorough tests and that where that's
where you have your integration test
your tests against contracts
uh even some uh even some light
end-to-end testing that i would classify
as smoke testing typically very very
simple cases where you can just see does
this work what kind of where there's
smoke there's fire kind of uh situations
each one of these these uh these steps
is designed to give you fast feedback if
things fail that should be relevant
feedback for a developer that's getting
that information uh if it fails because
of irrelevant things that's a problem in
your system you need to correct it uh
that's what i spend a lot of time doing
on release engineering is trying to
correct those irrelevant failures that
crop up from time to time
this whole stage in an ideal world
5 to 15 minutes
why that number because that's about as
long as you can go before things start
leaving your brain um
i mean i i maybe you're different some
people might might be able to hold
problems in their head longer but uh i'm
not i mean i probably have two minutes
uh
you know
what's the shiny thing going on but uh
no five to 15 minutes it's enough time
to get coffee it's enough time to have a
smoke break it's enough time to to
you know i don't know check slack
although that may be more distracting
depends on how you uh how you deal with
distractions but uh anyways it's really
critical that this thing stay stays very
fast and if it starts to creep above
this number and you don't do anything
about it it can cause a lot of problems
and it can become very very very
difficult to get it back down again
after that you want to have a code
review stage typically which is a human
stage this is a
not a
i mean you can have manu
processes that help you with code review
but typically this is a human looking at
things
guided by information they see from
continuous integration maybe that's
helping them make that decision um but
you know of course you don't want to
merge things that have failing tests but
uh you know then after that we can talk
about merging
we move on to our continuous delivery
stage which is typically seen as a more
mature phase of this but uh it requires
a little bit more automation on your
side we start moving on to places like a
staging environment could be any
alternate testing environment
from there if we have problems uh say
doing things like load testing or
performance testing we can roll back and
question whether we really should emerge
in the first place you can always revert
things emerge is not permanent uh don't
be afraid of merging um
this whole system should be designed to
help you get have confidence
not make you have be more scared because
you have to merge
from there another cool thing we can do
is something called canary deployments
where we actually start
talking about deploying to different
parts of our production environments
just little slices of it uh to see
how does this work it's one of the nice
things about
software as a service is you get to do
stuff like that
and as you know as we get more
information we use our monitoring and
observability tools to see how our code
is doing we can move it to the rest of
production
as a side note kind of at the end i
mentioned feature flags which is a way
we can actually you know change the the
behavior of software and production even
without doing code changes it's the way
you build in um configurability into
your code uh
as it goes so that for example you can
dark launch uh features you can say i
want to ship this but i don't want to
turn it on yet once i test it in a few
places out in production and i turn it
on make it general availability for
somebody betas are a good example of
this
but you can actually get really
sophisticated with this and many uh
companies that do this effectively at
scale do
this process if you thought fifteen five
to fifteen minutes or ci was scary then
15 to 30 minutes for deployment should
be probably a little bit scarier
but
there's good reasons why you want those
times
in the case of continuous delivery why
you want that that short time is because
it
you end up being exposed to a lot of
risk if you don't have it
if it takes you a long time to do it do
a deployment it will take you a long
time to do a roll back and that will
make you scared that will increase a lot
of fear in in your system having easy
rollbacks and having easy deployments
will continue to give you confidence
that you can fix bugs you can you can
pass security issues you can do things
on the fly
and uh even though it's a lot of work it
inspires a lot of confidence
the last important part of this whole
picture is that you need an overall meta
feedback mechanism from your continuous
delivery process back into your ci
if you discover bugs later in the system
that the one of your first impulses
should not be just to fix the bug but
also to write a fast test that can
reproduce that bug
in your uh in your in your ci system
uh that otherwise you're going to end up
with regressions otherwise you're never
going to be improving the ci system and
you'll lose confidence in it because
it's not actually solving the problems
that you were aiming to solve in the
first place
like i mentioned before the the time
thing waiting is a time sink you are
burning money
uh
i i don't i think if we understood how
much money we actually lose just by
waiting for bills to complete by waiting
for tests to come back
we would spend a lot more invest a lot
more on these kinds of things
like i said it increases recovery time
it increased exposure to your security
bugs
it has a lot of negative effects on
developers
slowness tends to lead to complexity
not only you know like i said developers
you're not going to keep things in your
head more than 5 10 15 minutes
so when you get the test result back
later it's you're thinking that must be
someone else's problem that can't really
be my code that's causing that problem
uh you'll have unloaded things from your
brain and context switched out
everyone i think in here kind of
probably knows when you're developing
you'd like you'd like to you know lock
in put on the headphones
uh you know get a good uh you know a bit
of flow going because you're loading a
lot of information in your brain and
reasoning about a lot of complex pieces
once you unload all that from your head
it's work to get it back in and if
you're switching between tasks because
you're waiting on ci to complete you're
just forcing this to happen all the time
for your developers every day
in addition it leads to a temptation to
batch which about what by that i mean
you put unrelated changes together
because you fear the you know a long ci
process because you fear that it's going
to take a long time to get your changes
through and you don't want to go through
that process again
this really decreases localizability uh
imagine if you're an operator and you
found a bug in production
and you're trying to isolate the cause
what that is and you go to a commit and
there's a bunch of weird unrelated
things that that have been lumped
together and you don't know why and
there's no description for it you're
going to have a hard time figuring out
how to how to deal with that and you
might end up reverting
whole changes to deal with it because
someone batched and they batched because
they were waiting for a ci to complete
why do we get slow pipelines
the main reason is because we we build
our systems in ways that are hard to
test uh and are hard to build uh in
small increments um
and that goes down to lack of having a
lack of contracts between what
components are supposed to do
sometimes it's just because we don't you
know we're just trying to get something
to work and we don't really care about
this stuff
uh and we don't really consider it as a
design constraint uh
another element that plays a big part in
this is having really coarse grain
dependencies uh and what i mean by that
is when you have say you know component
a needs um dependency x in order to work
but
you don't have a to x as a dependency in
your system you have all of a b c d e
and f need x now because you don't have
any more fine grained way of determining
what belongs to what so assigning
meaningful dependencies and having
smaller build units uh can actually
speed these things up in in a big way
i'll skip this for now um
if you were talking about um having uh
contracts and how would you divide this
up i wanted to go through kind of a
quick case study of what this might look
like
how we can um
do this this is an example of something
we do at ivan
this is a real thing we do sometimes
when we need to rescue machines
from
we need to rescue machines from a
situation where they filled up their
disk
we'll need we'll actually use cloud
technology to add more disk to that
machine
um extend volumes uh get what we need
done and then get moved to the next
machine that has the right disk space
again it's an important
tool for certain situations we can't
come up in operations
so this process is really owned by our
ops team but it crosses the boundaries
of three different teams uh the the ops
sre team uh the cloud team that manages
you know cloud infrastructure and the vm
team that writes the software that sits
on all our vms
this process works like this
the an operator will issue the command
add vm volume which produces a work item
uh in a work queue
uh which is consumed by the cloud
resource manager which actually makes
the call to the cloud provider and says
hey add some more disk to this machine
and then when the disk is dynamically
added that machine can extend uh the
logical volumes there and then you have
more disk space
important use case uh for us
we have some tasks that run on this uh
and we have what we have eight public
clouds now is that right uh i think
something like that uh and
all kinds of different um
all kinds of different uh instance types
that end up going through there so in
order to run this effectively we have to
run tons and tons of this test uh and it
takes a long time because this is stuff
that happens in the cloud and actually
involves physical infrastructure
but in order to act but really a lot of
this stuff can be tested very well in
isolation we already have contracts here
the uh the work item itself that's a
contract
so all i have to test to know that this
part of it works right now i have to
test to know that the command works
right can you create a work item
that doesn't change that often so i
don't have to worry about it um for the
resource manager
the cloud api calls don't change that
often so i can just check can can i fake
up a work item and can you produce the
right uh the right api call uh code from
that that's most the check i need uh i'm
not saying i'm never gonna call this i'm
never gonna call the public clouds again
i'll test them some other times but i
don't need to test them every commit
that's a lot of resources and it's a lot
of wasted time because that doesn't
change that often
uh for the uh the extending logical
volumes that one's a bit trickier
because it's it's it's not obvious how
to test that in memory uh but we're
working on it uh and these are some of
the challenges that we face uh but still
by dividing things like this up we
actually are able to get this into tests
that can work at a ci level and then we
can take this whole test case and we can
keep running it you know on a daily
basis or whatever and get more
information out of it but we're not
blocking developers because the only way
we know because because the only way we
know to test this is to string it all
together and see if it works we actually
have been able to divide this
meaningfully into small pieces and
assert that each piece works as it's
supposed to
there's more to quality than ci
you don't um
i think a lot of people when you start
doing ci systems you think that all my
tests need to run all the time in in ci
systems and once you you realize that
you don't have to stop testing when
you're done with ci you can test later
you can have cron jobs that run tests
you know one every time and generate
bugs for people uh that's perfectly fine
uh you need a different it's a different
feedback mechanism it's this test fails
create a you know create a ticket in
your uh in your work tracking system uh
and you know pass that to the developers
in charge of that thing it's a little
bit it's a longer feedback mechanism and
you need to make sure you actually
exercise those tickets otherwise
the whole thing falls apart
but
it means that you get those long
expensive tests out of the way of your
developer's day-to-day work
and you can use the the longer running
test
as a feedback mechanism for your shorter
feedback mechanism
other places for testing besides ci are
things like staging environments you can
set up a separate environment that's
very very very close to your production
environment and run continuous tests on
that
like i said you can do canary
deployments uh which you know deploying
to just little parts of your system
or what some people are doing more and
more these days is something called
multi-tenancy and production and this is
just using your production system but
using data isolation to uh
for you have a test tenant uh that that
owns this data uh and you can handle
building and things through that uh but
that's uh so you're just using your
production system and you use your
production monitoring tools and things
to monitor it uh to see if things work
that um that's actually a really cool
way to
to exercise your automated uh rollout
and deployment mechanisms uh as well so
it's advanced but it's a very powerful
tool uh one of the cool things about
being in software and software as a
service is that you get to test in
production in the old days when we
shipped software and you know as like it
went to the client and then you had to
configure it and then you had to leave
them alone
you didn't get to do these things uh
because once it was there if there's a
bug it's a long process to fix it but
now that we actually manage our own our
own systems
uh we can do this much easier
uh like i mentioned before many times
canary deployments are really cool you
can if you have enough traffic if you
have you can benefit from scale and 10
of your your uh your your customer base
will be enough to find a lot of things
that you didn't find in ci and
you can and usually if your blast radius
uh on your changes is small enough it's
fine you can either just roll back or
you can fix forward you can make that
the choices you see
uh this effectively replaces traditional
qa
you just use your customers as your qa
and
you have to have really good controls in
your system to do this properly but you
know it's a great way to save money
and keep moving forward in confidence
if there's anything that i want you to
take away about what ci is about it's
about the simple answer being able to
answer these simple questions
uh with confidence can i merge can i
deploy and are my gates doing their job
of giving me this confidence if they're
not if if you have a if you have a pass
in ci and you feel uncomfortable about
merging then your ci is not doing its
job right
if you if you constantly don't know when
you should deploy or what you should
deploy then your cd is not doing its job
right
so lastly i want to talk up just an
overview of a few tools that can allow
you to be a little bit more effective in
this uh nothing you know
nothing huge here but just some options
that you may want to explore
um
just as a note before all of this the
kind of rapid releasability and
automatic deployment automatic rollback
mechanisms that we were talking about
this takes hard work and it usually
takes designing for it specifically
retrofitting that into a system that
wasn't built for it can be quite a
daunting task that takes coordination
from multiple parts of your organization
so
i want to convince you that this pays
off in a huge way by not wasting your
developers time by giving you a lot of
confidence and not letting you fear
things that happen in production
but it's not going to happen overnight
and you need to convince people in your
org that this is worth it
that being said there's some of these
practices that can really help along the
way
i'm a big fan of trump-based development
which is uh often opposed to say feature
branch development where you would keep
uh
in a feature branch normally you're
going to keep your feature going until
you think it's good enough to merge and
then merge it to me that's the opposite
of what continuous integration means
continuous integration means constantly
integrating your code
back into things as you can
this is made a little bit easier by
things like feature flags i mentioned
before where you can do stuff by start
implementing a change hide it behind a
flag
and then keep implementing and getting
it better until you're ready to turn
that flag on and say okay now this is
ready to go um feature flags can be as
simple as uh
as configuration files you can just mock
up a json file that this is
featureflags.json uh you can put them in
the database or there there are whole
full-fledged feature flag frameworks out
there that uh companies that have edge
devices will use to decide which which
devices actually run which lines of code
you don't need that to make this work
you can start as simple as a you know a
json file like i said
but you know it's a really powerful way
to keep merging uh keep integrating
without
breaking things all the time
you'll also want to have smaller
pipelines if there's anything you've
gotten away from this the one of the
ways that that
that you can manage large systems is by
chunking them into smaller pieces
there's not really another good way to
do it so the easiest way to start making
smaller pipelines is if you have
something that's well isolated just
split it off into a smaller project
i know
not every company wants to do this all
the time but it you know it can work
really well you can also do things that
detect changes by location most ci
systems offer a way to say okay the
changes were in this group of files run
this pipeline the changes were in this
group of files run this pipeline
those are cool those are pretty simple
the problem with them is that you have
to end up managing the interdependencies
between those pipelines which itself can
be kind of complicated if you have a lot
of complex interdependencies there's
monorepo tooling which
can do this in a very very very
sophisticated way where you can say okay
this part of my code base changed that
means i need to run this test and and
all of its transitive dependencies
because you know this depends on this
which depends on this which depends on
this
that's a sophisticated tool check out
monorepo.tools to learn more if you're
interested interested in this you'll
need to select one that's right for your
language and your deployment environment
these are very complex tools that make a
lot of kind of crazy assumptions about
how you work so this is a solution that
you should
if you choose you should
choose it with care
but
you can it can help solve some of these
problems if you already have
complex interdependencies
observability is a real key issue here
as well um when
i know observability is another buzzword
and maybe it gets overused as a
marketing term but it's actually really
cool as a developer if you're able to if
you can meet that 30 minutes to
production um
you know
target time that means you can
merge your change and you can watch it
go out in production on your
observability systems and see hey did
things go wrong are things going right
you can do your own like basic
acceptance testing by just watching you
know the graphs or watching the
monitoring systems
it can also allow you to have things
like automatic automated rollbacks if
certain thresholds are met or whatever
so and we'll talk with your sre teams
talk with your devops teams about this
as i mentioned before none of this works
without heavy investment and deployment
automation if there's any part of your
deployment that requires a manual step
other than just pushing the button to do
it uh then you're doing it wrong
it absolutely all needs to be automated
it needs to work really well all the
time
and there's no better way to make sure
it works well all the time than doing it
really often
likewise rollback automation is the is a
key to giving you real confidence to
deploy uh if you can roll back a change
you have no reason to fear making the
change in the first place
uh this is pretty easy for software
generally it's a little bit harder when
you start talking about database schemas
and things like that um
so i'm not going to say that's going to
happen overnight for every change um but
you know
the the googles the facebooks the
github's the world make heavy
investments in this this kind of thing
and it's because it gives their
developers a lot of freedom to make
rapid changes all the time
if you are going into code that you
don't trust and you want to start adding
this kind of
did these kinds of features to it and
adding these kinds of tests you may
struggle with this particular conundrum
which i have many times of when you
approach some old code that you want to
make changes to because you need to add
you know the ability to
release rapidly
you look at and so i need to refactor
this i don't i don't know what's going
on here
you can't refactor without tests
but i can't really write tests on this
code without refactoring it or i can
maybe i can hack together some mocks or
something but
that's a hard situation to be in but
there are tools available um these are a
couple of books these are old books that
talk mostly about java and c plus plus
um
if even if you don't work on those
languages um
especially working effective with legacy
code has um
kind of really
that's revolutionized the way i look at
legacy code like i can go in i can be
confident and figure out ways to
actually test things you can uh there's
a lot of tricks in there that are really
practical
and some of it's going to put on the
language you're using but uh that you
know i definitely recommend those things
for new code i'm a big fan of
test-driven development a lot of people
don't like this because it has a
terrible name uh it's it's really i
should be called something like example
guided development or something else
it's not a testing methodology it's a
way of writing code that produces
testable code
i actually don't write that many tests
when i do tdd
i
just i write enough tests to know that
my code is testable and then if things
fail later i can always add more tests
and that's what's really great about it
is i get to solve that problem of oh if
i see a problem in production i want to
add a fast test it's uh the spot is
there to and ready to do it ready to
accept it
i'll skip this for now we're kind of
running out of time
uh another uh this is just a good movie
i couldn't find a better picture for
this uh but uh
uh another really important thing is you
you'll have sometimes systems that you
cannot really mock out so you'll need to
invest in having quality fakes okay
um
i've been doing this a lot right now
we're kind of running out of time so i
want to skip down to the
last thing question i want to ask you is
uh the canada developers at your company
accomplish things in your org that they
couldn't accomplish other places do your
processes enable them to
to move faster to build more
uh
than they could if they were somewhere
else if not then maybe you need to be
investing more in these processes in in
these tools
my name is josh reed you can find me on
twitter where i do nothing
but maybe if you dme or something i'll
respond i don't know
linkedin there's my contact information
i work in release engineering at ivan.io
we don't sell a cicd product but we do
sell
some cool database stuff and data
streaming technologies if you're tired
of managing that by hand maybe you can
free up some time to focus on
your processes and less time focusing on
your databases